welcome back to glamour unfiltered
praised by me josh smith and today we're
joined by the
international global sensation herself
it's an interesting seem so in tune
with your body like you're like yeah i'm
in my skin
i love my skin i'm working my body but
for you what's your
own journey with your idea of body image
been like
how has that changed and shaped you
so i have a lot of plastic surgeries
okay
it's not that um i accept my
imperfections because i mean for example
uh
satellites that's something that i have
more than oxygen inside me
more than water i have satellites more
than anything else in my body
and there's no such a treatment that
that can change this reality there is no
plastic surgery to take up facilities so
there's nothing i can do i can do diets
which i
hate i can do i can work out which i
also hate
so i'm not gonna have a life that i
don't like just to take out my cellulite
you know
i prefer to live with that and accept it
and say
okay if you don't like it's your problem
i'm not gonna take this problem to me
so i prefer to be happy with this and
don't care about and be like okay if you
like
good if you don't buy it's your problem
you know
i don't hide it i don't feel like oh my
god let me hide my satellites because
i just put it in the music video if
people like fine it's dumb
fine too yeah that's so amazing i think
it's so important as well
that you can be so honest about it as
well because
i think there's so much judgment like
we're saying that goes back into
having plastic surgery and wanting to
embrace your imperfections like there's
still so much judgement around that as
well isn't there
yeah and people are always like oh love
yourself
love yourself but they they never say
when they change to something
love yourself oh but i didn't love i did
sometimes in search of it but i'm not
gonna say but love yourself
i mean love yourself if you can change
good go there change it don't don't
waste your time
caring about i have some friends that
are like oh
i wish i could change this or that but
i'm so afraid of what people are gonna
say i'm like what
you don't change because of what people
are gonna say
i mean you know
or um when the person cannot change
something i just say hey
just get the positive things of this you
know
get the positive side of the things that
you don't like i
i still have some things that i don't
like on my body but
i don't get this like i i don't i'm not
like
oh i'm always like okay
let me find a way to make it be positive
somehow you know
and uh i think it's important more on
the internet
because the internet makes the
teenagers and the young people feel like
that they don't feel the reality the
real life you know
they have this uh i think it's hard this
difficulty
for them to look at the real life and
and
and understand that it's different
things the internet is one thing
nobody's gonna post like
oh today i woke up so sad people are
gonna post
beautiful things they're not gonna fall
like oh today my lunch was
a piece of ad because i had no time no
yeah
beautiful days so i always tell my
audience to don't
uh take internet life like
real life you know it's different it's
your beauty your rules babe
at the end of the day isn't it yes
that's what it's about
i love it i like to be honest with my
people you know one of the things
i love about you is how you use your
voice
and your platform to raise um
issues and shed light on the issues that
we all need to be talking about
and you are one seriously powerful human
and i think that needs to be celebrated
more
what for you do you think you're the
proudest of shedding a light on
you know what i wasn't like that before
i wasn't i i didn't know
that my my voice or my social medias or
it could change something you know i
didn't i didn't realize that
even because you were always seeing so
many
bad comments on the internet that you
don't feel like you
have this power or you can change
something in
some history you know and then it was
the
the last elections for president here in
brazil
and the audience started to ask me like
a position
so who are you gonna vote for what
you're gonna do
you're not gonna say anything and um
i realized how much these people care
about
uh influential or or potential people
people's opinion and then when i
realized
that i started to study about it because
i don't like to get involved or to say
something that i don't know how to get
the conversation till the end you know
i like to know everything that i'm
talking about because if you ask me 100
questions about the subject i'm gonna go
to the end talking to you like
yeah that's it that's it that's it so i
try to use my social media to be
to give some voice for it you know i
have these
millions and millions of followers so i
think i can use this for
for a good reason you know oh my god 100
and you were saying that you haven't
always been
this vocal with your voice and yeah your
voice to this level
for you going through your life what
have been some kind of
hurdles or stumbling blocks you've come
up against where you've been like oh
maybe i won't use my voice in this
situation but you wish you had or
kind of like social constructs and
sexism that stopped you from
using your voice in the way that you are
now yeah
uh definitely when i see uh something
wrong
like for example right now the
government in my country
sucks completely so they are always
messing up things and doing bad stuff
like uh
homophobic uh
talks and uh even the president and the
decisions that he takes for
them for the amazon for our forest for
our nature
when i see things like that when it
involves
um social calls like uh
lgbt uh community
or uh the the
environment thing that i think our
country has such an amazing
nature it's we have the power to be like
one of the biggest uh countries in the
world because look at the size that we
have
look at our nature look at how blessed
we are with
all of these uh different kinds of of
environments
and it looks like the government doesn't
give a [ __ ] about it you know they're
just caring about making money money
money
for themselves and not for the country
so when i see
things like that i really like to get
involved for you as well what do you
think
sitting here today is the most
pressing issue for you i think that
people judge a lot when you decide to be
like i decided when i
once since i was a little kid
i was like that you know i have my
opinion i say whatever i want to say
i like to dance i like to even when i
was a kid
i used to like to have like little
shorts and
tops you know i was like that since
i remember myself alive you know so
um as i decided to get this position
i feel like people don't respect or they
don't feel like you can be talented or
intelligent or respected
if you decide to be sexy or
dance or just speak about talk about sex
like openly
and um that's the biggest issue that
i've
that i feel when people are like oh okay
she got
everything that she has with her ass and
i say okay try to go there and get
everything that i have with your
ass so let's see what happens you know i
think something you picked
up on there which is so interesting is
these
outdated views that we still have
on women globally when it's like you
can't
dress in a certain way and be you know
successful you always have these
reductive
stereotypes that are placed on you and i
think for you as well when you came out
and you were very honest about being
bisexual and all that kind of stuff and
all the reductive stereotyping that
comes with that
how have you dealt with that well um
i try to think about all of the things
that i've done
you know every time that i see people um
underestimating me on something i try to
think about
all of the things that i've done that
nobody has done
uh coming from the place that i've come
that i've came from like um
i grew up in a favela area you know
surrounded by these things that um
if you're not born rich here in brazil
you don't even get the chance or good
opportunities to learn
language or arts music culture it's so
hard
so when i see this kind of behave
i i i don't have i used to have to be
more patient about it
and i think i think that now after the
time is
passing i feel like i'm not that patient
anymore
so i'm a little bit of aggressive with
uh when i
deal when i face people underestimating
me
or judging me by like oh you're a woman
oh she shakes her ass
if you could sit the you down
who was starting out the beginning of
your career on this soon call
and i was you starting out at the
beginning of your career what would you
want to say to her
right now i wouldn't say anything
because i think it's important for me to
to commit mistakes so i can learn i
think there is nothing better
than than learning with the mistakes
i've learned a lot with with the
mistakes that i've done
and for example i would have said don't
trust
everybody because i trust everybody
there's a funny story there is this um
this flight attendant that he was so
sweet with me
i was going to miami from brazil to
miami and there was his flight
flight attendant he was so sweet and i
really liked him
and but i have this this thing
on me that i always get people into my
house i always
help everyone i don't ask anything in
charge it's my way to be since i was a
little girl and i had
zero money i was like that so there was
this flight attendant and then my mom
was like
pissed because it was being a time that
some people
[ __ ] me up from the back and i was
really sad but i
i met this flight attendant and i loved
him
and i was like oh you're so sweet give
me your phone number
and he was like you're asking me your
my phone number and i was like yeah
you're sweet and
it was like he gave me his phone number
and like after
one week he was in my house and i
introduced him to my mom
and my mom was like who is this person
and i was like
here's a sweet flyer center that i just
met
and my mom was like you have to stop
because then after you bring these
people home
you help these people and after you
these people are bad with you
you cry with us after now it's been like
three years
and this flight attendant is her best
friend
he became to be here but he's not even
my
best friend anymore i mean we still talk
but they are together every week she
loves him more than anything so
uh when i was a little girl
i used to do this i used to be like that
too and my family they
always told me don't trust everybody
don't trust
everybody and that would be the same um
advice i would give to myself as a
little girl
don't trust everybody because i've been
uh into very bad situation
situations because i trusted people but
also
when we get the chance to to have a good
moment like
giving my mom a best friend which she
doesn't she didn't have
before it's so good and i prefer to go
living a life and having my face broken
sometimes
in exchange of some other times we have
a
good moment yeah i love it babe it's
been
amazing talking to you you're the queen